je fais ça pour les pourboires quatre
heures en vadrouille tout ce que je
récolte c'est un vieux tickets resto
périmés pull qui pue le racisme ça
devrait vous aller comme un gant aux
livraisons à 1000 benzine c'est pas ma
zone de livraison
c'est pour moi etes-vous déterminé à
investir dans votre future wii
réclamer ce qui vous est dû oui
etes-vous prêts quel qu'en soit le prix
à vous consacrer à satan oui
qui êtes vous je suis libraire de la
livreuse est ce que par hasard vous
seriez
encore vierge c'est un peu personnel ça
les vierges qui a le pouvoir de révéler
notre véritable potentiel
vous savez pas ce qui se trame ici ils
vont invoquer le dieux des sans faire
quelques en l'horloge nature à nous il
ressuscitera à travers vous
où se trouve cette vierge je comprends
rien à ce qui se passe
ma mère et ses potes ont intention
d'invoquer baphomet tu risques de finir
lido thé avec du fil barbelé un hôtel
quelle pervers vous savez pourquoi les
riches restent riches
vous restez faucher ils ont une bonne
assurance ils sont plus forts que tout
pas de sacrifice faible longue vie aux
puissants faut qu'on arrête de boire qui
veut vraiment les affronter savoir
étroitement cette quinzaine